ANALYST WHO COVERS MONEY AND
POLICY.
FIRST, WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU.
LET ME START WITH YOU.
THE ESTIMATE, THE EXPECTATION
8.8% WAS BAD, 9.1% WORSE.
PUT IT IN CONTEXT.
>> 8.8% WAS THE EXPECTATION,
WHICH WAS HIGHER THAN THE TOP
LINE NUMBER LAST MONTH.
SO WE WERE ALREADY EXPECTING AN
ACCELERATION.
THIS CAME IN HIGHER THAN THAT.
IT WAS EYE POPPING.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
GAINS, THE BIGGEST CONTRIBUTORS,
GASOLINE, NEARLY 60% HIGHER.
SO WE TALK A LOT ABOUT GAS.
THAT SAID, THE REPORT WAS
BROAD-BASED.
WE SAW INFLATION PRETTY MUCH
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THIS WAS A HUGE FROM THE FOR THE
FED.
WE WERE HOPING WE HAD A REPORT
REPEAT.
>> DYLAN, HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
WHITE HOUSE'S REACTION.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD SAID CORE
INFLATION HAD COME DOWN, SO THEY
THINK THAT'S A GOOD SIGN.
HE ALSO SAID WHILE TODAY'S
HEADLINE INFLATION READING IS
UNACCEPTABLY HIGH, IT'S ALSO OUT
OF DATE.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
>> SO THE ISSUE WITH MARKETS AND
ECONOMIES AND POLITICIANS OF ALL
STRIPES IS THERE IS NO ISSUE
WHERE THEY ARE MORE MISALIGNED
BECAUSE POLITICIANS OF ANY
STRIPE ALWAYS WANT TO -- THEY
DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE ACTIONS
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO ACTUALLY
DEAL WITH INFLATION, AND NO ONE
CAN BLAME THEM BECAUSE WHO WANTS
TO TAKE GAS PRICES AND INTEREST
RATES TO 10, SO I DON'T THINK
ANYONE WILL DO THAT.
IT BECOMES THIS RITUAL OF WORDS
LIKE THE PRESIDENTS TODAY, AND
AT THE SAME TIME, PRIVATELY
ALARMING MEETINGS TO THE POINT
ABOUT THE 9% NUMBER AND THE
SHOCKING NATURE OF THE HEADLINE
WHICH REALLY JUST INTRODUCES --
PEOPLE REALLY WANTED TO THINK
THAT MAYBE THE FED WILL RAISE
RATES ONE MORE TIME AND THEN
THEY'LL BE DONE AS OPPOSED TO
HAVING TO GO ALL THROUGH NEXT
YEAR.
SO EVERY TIME YOU GET
SIGNIFICANT DATA LIKE THE ONE WE
RECEIVED TODAY, IT REDUCES THE
PROBABILITY THAT THE FEDERAL
RESERVE STOPS MOVING EARLY, AND
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
OR ANY POLITICIAN WANTS TO HEAR.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO
ALMOST JAWBONE THE FED IN A
SENSE WHERE HE'S SAYING, WELL,
YEAH, IT'S A BAD HEADLINE, BUT
THE CORE INPUTS ARE NOT THAT BAD
AND IT'S A TRAILING INDICATOR,
AND YOU DON'T ARE TO RAISE
INTEREST RATES MUCH MORE.
THAT'S THE UNSPOKEN PIECE OF
THAT.
>> THE MARKETS ARE DOWN, DOW IS
DOWN.
HOW MUCH OF THIS IS BAKED IN?
I MEAN, THAT'S -- DOWN 181.
>> YEAH.
WELL SINCE THE START, WE HAVE
LOST 14 TRILLION, IN MANY CASES
34% OF ALL GLOBAL ASSET VALUES
OVER THE LAST SIX MONTHS.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, IT'S
ALMOST ALL PRICED IN.
THE BOND AND EQUITY MARKETS HAVE
ALREADY REPRICED FOR THE
EXPECTATIONS OF AN ECONOMIC
SLOWDOWN.
CALL IT A RECESSION, BUT THE
SLOWDOWN IS A SURE THING.
IT'S NICE TO HAVE OIL COMING OFF
A BIT.
BUT THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
HOPE DEVELOPING MAYBE NOT EVEN
WITH A STRONG BASIS THAT THE FED
WOULD NOT HAVE TO CONTINUE TO BE
AGGRESSIVE, BUT IN ORDER FOR
THAT HOPE OR THAT FANTASY OR
THAT WISH, WHETHER YOU'RE A
TRADER OR AN INVESTOR OR A
POLITICIAN TO EVEN HAVE A CHANCE
TO BE TRUE, YOU NEED NUMBERS
LIKE THE CPI TO COME IN BELOW
EXPECTATIONS.
THAT'S WHY YOU GET A LITTLE
SELLOFF TODAY BECAUSE YOU'RE
LIKE, SO MUCH FOR THE FED
STOPPING SOON, BUT AT THE SAME
TIME, THE MARKET'S ALREADY BEEN
DESTROYED BECAUSE OF THE
ADJUSTMENT ON THE ASSET SIDE,
AND IT HASN'T EVEN STARTED TO
PLAY OUT AS IT'S GOING TO OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS IN TERMS OF
SO MANY THINGS.
>> AND GUYS, I MEAN, THE FED AND
CHAIRMAN POWELL HAVE BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT THEY ARE LOOKING FOR
MONTHLY CORE INFLATION.
I'M SURE THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
ALL OF THE NUMBERS COME DOWN,
BUT SURELY MONTHLY INFLATION
COME DOWN.
WE SAW PRICES INCREASE 7/10 OF A
PERCENT.
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC FOR THE FED
BECAUSE IT NOW MEANS THE FED
WILL HAVE TO DO MORE RATHER THAN
LESS TO TRY TO TAME INFLATION
AND A MORE AGGRESSIVE FED MEANS
THE LIKELIHOOD OF OVERDOING IT,
OF TRIGGERING A RECESSION GOES
UP.
THAT'S THE CONCERN.
>> LET'S PULL UP FOOD PRICES
THAT EVERYBODY CAN RELATE TO.
IN THE PAST YEAR, FOOD IS UP
12.2%, BUT IF YOU BREAK IT DOWN,
CEREAL AND BREAD, EGG 13.8,
DAIRY 13.5.
EGGS 33.1.
OBVIOUSLY, THE VOTERS ARE
HOLDING PRESIDENT BIDEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
>> THE BLUNT ANSWER FOR THAT,
YOU HAVE TO ADJUST THE
SANCTIONS.
THIS IS NOT AN INFLATION
ISSUE -- YOU HAVE A PREEXISTING
REALITY FOR A DECADE, AMERICA
AND THE WORLD HAD FREE MONEY,
SHOCKING INFLATION TOOK THIS
LONG.
WE HAVE BEEN ON FREE MONEY SINCE
2009.
BUT IT DIDN'T.
PREEXISTING FREE MONEY.
THEN YOU HAVE SUPPLY CHAIN
PINCHES, AND THEN THE FINAL
THING YOU HAVE IS THE UKRAINE
INVASION, WHICH IN AND OF IT IS
DISRUPTIVE TO OIL AND GRAIN, AND
THEN YOU HAVE THE ADDITIONAL
POLITICAL STRATEGIC DECISION TO
USE ECONOMIC SANCTIONS IN AN
EFFORT TO TRY TO STOP RUSSIA.
AND THE COST OF DOING THAT
SPECIFICALLY TO EUROPE AND THE
UNITED STATES IS HIGHER FUEL AND
FERTILIZER COSTS, WHICH ARE THE
MOST ACUTELY FELT BY FARMERS,
WHICH IS WHY THEY'VE STOPPED
GROWING FOOD IN EUROPE THIS
SUMMER BECAUSE THEY NO LONGER
HAVE A PROFIT MARGIN BECAUSE OF
FOOD AND FUEL COSTS AND IT'S WHY
AMERICANS ARE NOT HAPPY WITH
THEIR PRESIDENT BECAUSE THE COST
OF GAS AND I'M SURE THE FARMERS
ARE NOT HAPPY BY THAT COST.
SO IF YOU WANT REAL POLITIC, I
GUESS THEY CALL IT, THEY HAVE TO
ADJUST.
THESE SANCTIONS ARE EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE POLITICALLY ON NATO
AND THE UNITED STATES AND THUS
FAR, THEY HAVE MADE RUSSIA
STRONGER.
THE RUBLE IS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL IT'S BEEN AND RUSSIA'S
PARTICIPATION IN THE GLOBAL OIL
MARKETS IS HIGHER THAN IT WAS
BEFORE THE WAR, WHICH I WOULD
SAY ARE -- AND THEY'RE STILL IN
UKRAINE.
SO I THINK YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT THIS QUESTION AFTER ALL
THIS TIME, ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO FUEL AND FERTILIZER.
WHICH IS NOT JUST INFLATION.
THAT'S THE DIRECT COST OF THOSE
SANCTIONS.
>> I APPRECIATE YOU LAYING OUT
ALL THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
BECAUSE THEY ARE MIND-BLOWING.
>> I THINK THE RIS